Hôm nay, chúng ta sẽ không thật nào với Iran, ngoài đầu hàng vụ được kiệt.
Đông thoải đưa xem là làm giá tăng tăng thằng trong bối kại xung đột.
Tây Huran, với Linh Còn Mi Israel đã bước sẵn tận thứ 2,
của thẻ ông Trump Tuyên Lú sẽ không có thật nào với Iran, ngoài đầu hàng vụ được kiện trên mạng
sau hội chú xấu.
Đông thời để ngọt khả năng cùng, có đồng mình phú trở tại kết nền tình để Iran hậu xung đột.
Trở đó, ông cũng nói, Washington cần có tìm nói trong việc lựa chọn lại tụt tôi gà mời của Iran,
sau khi ông Ali Hammonday tìm mạng trong idol trên sử.
Đại sự Iran tại liên hậu của Amir C.E.E.
Iran và đi khẳng định việc lựa chọn lại đạo mời sẽ được tử viện theo diên pháp và hơi gó bất kỳs,
đang thiệp lực bệnh ngoài.
Tổng thống Iran mà sức t this kia ăn cho viết,
một số cua ra đã mắt đầu cân lúc tụt lại hả giải nhằm tìm kiếm dài pháp mọi giá ổ chọn của xung đột.
Trên thử viện, Israel sẽ tụt mở giống các cuộc tấn công vào Iran bà libang trong đó,
tiến hành không quyết dữ dữ dữu dữ phụt viện năm tụt về rút,
sau khi ra lạch sự gản quy mối lớn.
Iran cũng phòng tên lửa vào mời rời khung người lạy,
phải Israel cũng một số cua ra cũng vình có càng tự qua sự của Mỹ.
Lên quan tờ dịt biến truyền.
Mi đang rửa dịch app để sửa lần các không vui hướng góc thủy
tủy Iran sống sốt, sau khi tổ trên iris,
để nào bị đánh chim, mọi khương nơi trong một cuộc biển của tế.
Cung mời ông trọng cho biết đã gặp lãnh đạo bẩy tập loạn của phòng Mỹ để tụt lại tăng tốt,
sản xuất của khi phục buộng cho chân dịch.
Về phía Iran cũng ngay một số thống ba,
giữ trường này cho biết i rất một in và trọng pháp mẹ hai dân thường đã chết mạng
kể từ khi các cuộc tấn công bất đầu,
đông thời gian bảo,
các nước AIU tham gia tấn công Iran sẽ trở thành một điều hấp pháp.